prudemment progressivement le chemin de
l'activité économique
mais alors même que cette reprise est en
cours des pans entiers de notre économie
reste paralysée au premier rang desquels
celui des professionnels du tourisme que
nous avons réuni ce matin ils ont
formulé une angoisse que je peux
parfaitement comprendre et qui est
parfaitement légitime
angoisse face au présent face à la
réalité de cette crise sanitaire
angoisse face à l'avenir
ils ont également indiqué leur très
grande détermination en faire en sorte
que nous puissions dépasser cette étape
difficile
nous préparons les protocoles qui
permettront de ré ouvrir dès que cela
sera possible et nous aurons les
réponses des autorités sanitaires
au cours de la semaine du 25 mai sur les
dates et les modalités de réouverture
des secteurs touristiques
en attendant le gouvernement ne veut pas
prendre le risque de laisser sinistrés
un secteur si important pour le pays
je veux rappeler que la quasi totalité
du secteur a recours aujourd'hui au
chômage partiel et que 6,2 milliards
d'euros de prêts garantis par l'état ont
déjà été prêts accordés à 50 mille
entreprises du secteur soit au fond près
de 10% du total des prêts garantis par
l'état
les mesures que nous allons mettre en
oeuvre sur les suivantes le fonds de
solidarité restera ouvert pour les
entreprises du secteur hôtellerie
restauration tourisme jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2020 son accès sera élargie à
des entreprises de plus grande taille
celle qui jusqu'à 20 salariés jusqu'à 2
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
l'enveloppent des prêts tourisme de bpi
france qui sont plébiscitées par le
secteur sera porté de 250 millions à un
milliard d'euros
là aussi c'est une bonne nouvelle que ça
va permettre à beaucoup d'acteurs de
passer cette étape dans de bien
meilleures conditions
enfin mesures importantes les banques se
sont engagées à systématiquement
proposer aux pme du secteur
un report des mensualités de tous leurs
prêts sur douze mois et non pas
simplement sur les six mois comme
aujourd'hui sur le chômage partiel
les entreprises du secteur vont pouvoir
continuer d'y recourir dans les mêmes
conditions qu'aujourd'hui au moins
jusqu'à la fin
du mois de septembre 2020 au delà le
chômage partiel leur restera ouvert si
les activités reprennent trop lentement
dans des conditions qui seront le cas
échéant reçu plan d'investissements en
fonds propres de 1 3 milliard d'euros
sera portée par la caisse des dépôts et
par bpi france ce milliard 300 millions
d'euros va générer des investissements
privés qui vont s'ajouter à ce milliard
300 millions d'euros d'argent public
pour atteindre un chiffre global
d'environ 7 milliards d'euros
enfin nous allons soutenir la demande et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
allons doubler le plafond d'utilisation
des tickets restaurant à compter de la
réouverture des restaurants
si je fais la somme de tout ce que je
viens d'indiquer c'est un engagement de
plus de 18 milliards d'euros pour les
finances publiques c'est sans précédent
la question qui occupe tout le monde les
acteurs de ce secteur mais en vérité
tous les français c'est celle des
vacances d'été sous réserve de
l'évolution de l'épidémie et de
possibles restrictions très localisées
en fonction de son évolution
nous privilégions une hypothèse
raisonnable
les français pourront partir en vacances
en france au mois de juillet et au mois
d'août
et quand je dis en france c'est
évidemment en métropole dans l'hexagone
et dans les outre-mer les français
peuvent prendre leur réservation
les acteurs du tourisme les acteurs de
l'hôtellerie se sont engagés à faire en
sorte qu'il soit 1 intégralement
remboursé dans l'hypothèse où
l'évolution de l'épidémie ne rendrait
pas possible le départ en vacances parmi
les fédérations qui s'engagent je note
en particulier l'union des métiers et
des industries de l'hôtellerie
le groupement national des indépendants
le syndicat des tours opérateurs